Speaker 1: So we know intuitively and we
know because of what happened on January six
that there are some Republicans, some portion of
the Republican electorate that is willing to turn
to violence that sees violence as legitimate
or at least justified in order to achieve
their political goals. There's a new study from
the public public research a public little public
religion research institute that looks very
specifically at who are the Americans that are
willing to turn to violence to achieve their
political objectives. And we're going to look
at that right now. Salon summarizes this as an
alarming finding, but no surprise many Republicans
now ready to support violence. New EPRI poll
finds direct links between Trump's Big Lie,
far right media and support for potential
violence. New public opinion research,
the 12th Annual American Values Survey from the
Public Religion Research Institute has alarming
findings close to a third of Republicans. In
the survey, 30 percent agree with the statement.
True American patriots may have to resort to
violence in order to save our country. That's
more than the combined total of Democrats
and independents who say the same thing
at 11 and 17 percent, respectively. Let's look
at the numbers. We're going to look at some
other elements of the study because it's really
well done. Really interesting. The question was
how do you agree with the statement? True American
patriots might have to resort to violence in order
to save our country per party affiliation and
that attitude. So first of all, almost one
fifth of Americans do believe that true American
patriots might have to resort to violence to save
their country. All right, 18 percent of Americans
say yes. The largest group by party identification
is Republicans. 30 percent of Republicans believe
violence may be justified to save the country.
What's very interesting is that if you look at
their media consumption, the Republicans who trust
mainstream news. Only 22 percent believe they
may need to turn to violence. Of the Republicans
who most trust Fox News, the number goes up to 32
percent believe they may need to turn to violence.
And if Fox News is too liberal for Republicans and
they only trust far right news present presumably
stuff like Newsmax, OANN and conspiracy
stuff, then a full 40 percent of them,
40 percent believe that violence may
be justified, which is stunning. Now,
17 percent of independents and about one out
of 10 Democrats also believe the same. And in
terms of specific beliefs, if you believe that
the 2020 election was stolen from Donald Trump,
there's a four out of 10 chance that you also
believe violence may be necessary or appropriate.
If you believe God has granted America a special
role in human history, 27 percent chance OK,
so those are very, very disturbing numbers for
one very specific reason. There are 30 percent
of Republicans willing to admit in a poll
that they would be supportive of violence.
How many Republicans would be supportive of
violence, but aren't willing to admit it in a
poll? It's some number, for sure, and I don't know
exactly what that number would be, but that's also
a significant concern. Now there's lots of things
to look at in this study. Just a couple of others
in terms of attitudes, and I encourage you to
check we're linking to this. Check out the entire
study. One interesting question that was studied
is has the U.S. always been a force for good in
the world? And has there never been a time you
were not proud to be an American? So overall,
74 percent of Americans believe America has
always been a force for good in the world.
And 58 percent of Americans say there was never
a time. I was not proud to be an American. Not
surprisingly, Republicans are far more
likely to believe that than Democrats.
But it's not like Democrats are slouches.
The portrayal the stereotype, so to speak,
is Democrats don't really like the U.S.. Democrats
have a very anti-American attitude. If you look at
these questions, it's not that low. I mean, sick.
Two thirds of Democrats still believe America has
always been a force for good in the world by
the stereotypes of patriotism. It's not very
unpatriotic. OK? Among other groups, white
evangelicals and white non evangelical Protestants
seem to be the most stereotypically pro-American.
Now I say stereotypically, because for me,
being pro-American means very different things
than it means to these groups. But by these
definitions, followed by white Catholics and then
Hispanic Catholics, maybe not surprisingly, the
religiously unaffiliated are those least likely
to hold these stereotypically patriotic views
about the United States of America. One other
thing we kind of talk about this idea of
idealizing the 1950s that is prevalent among
the American right, and when they talk about
conserving and getting back to when America was
great, it's often the 1950s that they have in mind
one of the questions that this really is a great
study. You should you should really page through
it. People were asked, Do you think life has
mostly changed for the better since the 1950s?
Among Democrats, close to two thirds believe
life is better now than it was in the 1950s.
Among independents? About half believe life
is better now than it was in the 1950s.
Only 29 percent of Republicans believe that
life is now better than it was in the 1950s.
And that's very telling. When we think about
conservatism, what do they want to conserve?
What do they want to go back to?
And it seems as though it's often
this kind of 1950s idea. It's not wrong. It's
not wrong. It's not wrong to believe that the
last thing I want to look at, what traits do you
associate with being truly American? And a really
excellent question where you see agreement? Where
between all Americans, Republicans and Democrats,
there's not much of a difference are believing
in individual freedoms like freedom of speech.
Republicans and Democrats are basically united.
That is something that is truly American,
believing every citizen should be able to vote in
elections. Almost exact numbers between Democrats
and Republicans accepting people of diverse
racial and religious backgrounds, you start
to see a little bit of a split. Republicans,
slightly less than Democrats believe that.
But where you really start to see differences
is. Questions like being able to speak English
as being able to speak English,
a sign of being truly American.
93 percent of Republicans say yes. Whereas only
68 percent of Democrats say yes. Believing that
capitalism is the best economic system, you see a
27 point gap between Republicans and Democrats on
whether that is a sign of being really American
believing in God. There is a three point gap.
Almost 80 percent of Republicans believe that
to be truly American, you must believe in God.
Less than half of Democrats believe that.
And then an interesting one being of
Western European heritage, a sort of white
supremacist belief as being truly American.
One fifth of Republicans believe that, but almost
one fifth of Democrats believe that as well.
OK. Check out the study. We're linking to it and
recall, of course, that when it comes to this
openness to violence to solve political problems.
Recall that Republicans claim to be about law
and order until they are not. They claim to be
about supporting the police until January six,
when suddenly they didn't support the police.
They claim to be about business freedom until
some business has started saying, Hey, we want
our employees to be vaccinated against COVID.
Then they weren't about business freedom anymore.
I could spend the whole show giving you examples.
But the point here is they regularly fantasize
about things that they claim they don't want to
see. They claim they want to prevent the collapse
of society. And yet increasingly they're willing
to cause it in order to achieve what they
believe will be successful political outcomes.
I continue to see January 6th as a sort of trial
for more violence in the future. There have barely
been consequences for the writers so far, starting
to see some no consequences for the insiders,
including members of Congress. Trump staffers
Trump himself. And so it shouldn't come as a shock
to us that the number of Republicans willing
or who believe violence may be appropriate
to achieve political gain is as high as it
actually is. So send me your thoughts on that.